microsoft largue windows 7 même si le
logiciel est encore utilisée par 200
millions d'ordinateurs sur la planète
le pif 14 janvier microsoft offre plus
de soutien technique aux deux visages
eau pour le système windows 7
les ordinateurs fonctionnent toujours
mais dorénavant non seulement le
logiciel ne sera plus améliorée mais les
nouvelles failles de sécurité ne seront
plus détecté ce qui va rendre les
appareils plus vulnérables face aux
virus et aux logiciels malveillants
windows 7 est offert depuis plus de dix
ans le système est resté plus populaire
que les versions suivantes comme windows
8 10 k et expliquent qu'ils sont déjà
disparu microsoft propose de passer à
windows 10 qui existe depuis cinq ans et
qui est vendu 139 dollars windows 10 et
le logiciel d'exploitation le plus
populaire au monde et se retrouve sur
900 millions d'appareils
[Musique]